let's delve into AES and talk about you
know what's good about it how it works
and why it was judged good enough to be
the advanced encryption standard so why
yes yes what yeah why is a yes well why
behind are they have you heard of mine
doll crying doll no no okay so in that
perhaps slightly infuriating way I
managed to not say anything about how it
works in the last video at all let's
start with a few numbers that we briefly
mentioned in the last video my AAS is a
128-bit symmetric block cipher that
means it takes 128 bits of message and
it encrypts it into 128 bits of
ciphertext with some key now that key
can either be 128 192 or 256 bits and
that gives you just varying amounts of
security right form
loads too ridiculously lows right in my
opinion alright so don't worry about it
if you if you find your browsers using
128 bit that's okay these were specified
as part of the AES standard so and I'll
had to adhere to this but just think
that we're taking 16 bytes that's 128
bits and we're doing something to it
that turns it into some ciphertext and
because this is an SP network we're
going to be doing some amount of
substitution or completing in some
confusion and some amount of permutation
moving things around to add diffusion
you don't want just like the Enigma
machine you don't want to have one byte
in one byte out because it that's got to
be easier to analyze and in historically
of course it is instead of having a long
line of bytes or bits like most ciphers
might arrange things
AES likes to arrange things in a grid a
4x4 grid 428 bit so we have our message
which is 128 bit that's 16 bytes as a
4x4 grid every time I try and draw a
grid it always goes wrong
so byte naught is going to be in here
and byte 1 and by 2 and by 3 and then 4
5 6 7 says column major order so
actually what we're doing is we're
taking our 128-bit message and we're
just laying it out in this order like
this and then we're going to start doing
our SP network going to permute we're
going to substitute bytes and then
transform this into some way where an
attacker can't read what the message
used to be so there are a few different
operations that AES will do but remember
but everything in AES happens on this
4x4 grid all right so what we're going
to do remember we got the SP Network
we're going to have substitution
permutation and we're going to add
darken as well at some point so this is
our plaintext and we're going to first
bring in a part of our key and we're
going to perform an XOR operation we
know member we put in our key
intermediate between the rounds two
that's all secrecy the rest of the
algorithm is fully published in public
then we're going to do our round so
that's going to be substitute bytes then
we're going to shift rows and then
finally we're going to mix columns and
this is going to be our substitution and
this is going to be our permutation and
finally at the end of each round we're
going to add our key add around key like
this and then this is going to be one
round and the only thing to mention is
that the mixed columns is in all the
rounds except for the last one because
this permutation has no effect on the
last round it just pollutes the output
doesn't make doesn't make any different
so it's exactly like this except that
this one is missing on the last round
when you've got 128 bit key you have ten
of these rounds when you have 192 bit
key you have 12 of these rounds and when
you have a 256 bit key you have 14 of
these rounds but in all regard though
exactly the same so this is also an XOR
down here add round key we don't put the
same key in every time what we do is we
take the original key and as I mentioned
in the SP network video we expand it
using something called a key scheduled
in two different round keys so this
would be sort of key nought perhaps so
this would be key one key 2 and so on
depending on which round we were in and
so there'll be a key that's expanded for
every round we won't talk in too much
detail about that the key schedule is
quite simple and effect it's just meant
to be fast mainly it just takes your
you're shorter key and expands it
sufficiently such that you can put it in
at these different rounds that's an
overview of what a es does this is a
much much much better version I mean I
didn't I can't stress this enough a much
much better version than the one I
designed or showed in my SP Network
video right we're substituting and then
we're going to permute
and then we're going to mix in our round
key
and we're gonna do this over and over
again until we have a ciphertext so I
guess the question then becomes what
happens here here and here of interest
what's particularly nifty for me about
AES is that it doesn't use the same kind
of operations that you might expect
so XOR of course happens everywhere in
cryptography but actually all of the
operations within a AES are essentially
mathematical operations on what we would
call a finite field so Dave talked a
little bit about Galois fields in his
reed-solomon video and the answer is by
using Galois field theory over finite
fields and doing lots and lots of long
divisions and additions for a finite
field or Galois field which are
interchangeable names they what you have
in a field is you have some some number
of elements so let's say all the numbers
between Norton 10 for example right and
you have different operations you can
perform on that field so in mind our we
have a Galois field of two to the eight
elements and then in this field we can
do addition subtraction multiplication
and division or X to the minus one
inversion the important thing to
remember about a finite field if we
don't go any further with the math at
all is that two to the elements is a is
a byte
all right so each element in this Galois
field is just a bite so we start with
naught naught naught naught naught
naught naught naught we go all the way
to 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 11 to hundred and
fifty-six of these elements in this
particular finite field and the one
take-home message you need to know about
this even if you don't ever look at it
again is that whichever of these
operations we do we produce another
element in this field but we never leave
the field we never overflow we never
under flow and go you know into negative
numbers or anything there's no float
representation or anything like this if
we take one of these numbers and we add
them to another one we find a different
one and if we multiply them or inverse
invert them or divide we go through a
different one which makes it quite nice
for implementing a cipher because a lot
of these have an opposite so for example
addition and subtraction undo each other
multiplication and inversion or dividing
they undo each other and we can move
around this field
we never actually Levi bites if we've
got our 4x4 by representation of our
data path in AES this is our 128-bit
block we can perform operations on here
within this finite field and by the end
we'll still be in the finite field we
won't have gone over to 130 bits 140
bits or some disaster like that as well
bring the diagram back and with that in
mind we will talk about what each of
these does SATA 2 bytes that's our
substitution box is literally a lookup
table
it's a cleverly designed lookup table
they have just made this up each byte is
mapped to a different byte based on a
function in this field but most
importantly there's a few there's a few
things that they've done to try and
design it to be as complicated as
possible
alright so it's very nonlinear so it's
very difficult to kind of represent this
as a mathematical function exactly what
it is that it does in fact let's just do
one and then we couldn't we can see
right so we've got our grid let's put
this here we've got our grid now drawn
many times this is B 0 this is B 1 all
the way up to be 15 now what we're going
to do is we're going to take this byte
we're going to look it up in our table
and we're going to replace it with a
different one right so our substituted
byte like that and we're gonna do about
individually for each of these to make
this function more confusing it's been
designed such that there are no fixed
points that means no byte is substituted
with itself
so you don't start with a 15 and up with
a 15 and there are no opposite fixed
points which means all the bits flip so
for example the opposite of 100 100
would be oh one o one my emphasis for
the whole byte they don't exist in this
it's been designed that way so this
substitution box is really quite
powerful and it's one of the reasons why
this is a really good algorithm as it
happens also it's just a lookup table so
it's nice and quick that's the first
thing what so we've substituted our
bytes we've taken our plaintext we put
in part of our round key or s is our
initial key and then at the beginning
around will make some byte substitutions
using our s box then we're going to
shift the rows this is really
straightforward so we're just going to
take the first row and do nothing to it
we're going to take the second row we're
going to move it one to the left so b1
goes all the way back over to here all
right setting background this moves this
way and this moves this way and this
moves this way and this goes it goes to
the end this row moves two so this goes
to here this goes to here this goes
round
to here and so on and this moves three
right which is another way of saying it
moves that way but it you know so this
one goes all the way over to here this
one goes over to here and so and so on
remember this is going to be an
iterative process and what we want to do
is move these things around and permute
them so if this is our data path with
our columns by sharing bytes around the
different columns when we combine it
with the mixed column step which we'll
do in a minute you'll see that actually
we're mixing everything up so within
just a couple of rounds everything is
very very jumbled up and that's
obviously a really good thing because
it's going to be much much harder to
break alright so we're just taking bytes
and we're putting them in a different
place in this grid so that brings us to
mix columns which goes along with this
alright so now that we've moved things
into different columns what we're going
to do is we're going to take this column
here and we're going to mix these right
up we're gonna take this column and mix
these right up and this one and this one
separately so this is a column wise
operation so this byte has gone over to
here and then we mix into this column
this one has gone over to here and been
mixed into this column so these two
operations together are you know they're
doing a good job of jumbling everything
up right will be my technical way of
putting it this is going to be done
using a matrix multiplication so let's
just turn it off and go through a lot of
your paper today for some column let's
say C naught C 1 C 2 C 3 we're going to
multiply it as a vector by a matrix
right now we've dealt with major
applications occasionally computer file
we're not going to spend too much time
talking about it now but this matrix is
2 3 1 1 1 2 3 1 1 1 2 3 and 3 1 1 2 now
these numbers they're big enough and
jumbled enough that something
interesting happens here but it's small
enough that this is quite fast right on
Hardware implementations and things like
this if this was 50 it made your
algorithm slower so if you remember from
sort of linear algebra a matrix
multiplication is going to produce
another vector out so it's going to
replace this column of another one and
it's going to be a combination of all of
these so this one times this one plus
this one times this one plus this one
times this one plus this one times this
one and then we repeat this process for
each of the values so we're taking bits
and bytes from all of these in this
column jumbling them up moving them
around shifting them and there was a
reverse
inverse matrix but does the exact
opposite when you want to decrypt as
well so although this is doing a good
job of jumbling everything up we can
actually also undo it the only thing to
mention of course is this is not a
normal multiplication in the sense that
we're inside this more finite field so
our add operation is an XOR and our
multiplication operation is a
multiplication inside this finite field
right which is modulo a polynomial and
you know we'll sort of leave that for
someone to look into although we'll talk
about it in some extra bits so so I
guess like once once more from the top
we take our plain text and we XOR it
with the first part of our expanded key
and then we're going to repeat this
process over and over again so we're
going to substitute some bytes using our
nicely designed s box we're going to
shift the rows along and then we're
going to mix all the columns up so we're
going to substitute and then permute our
data in its grid then each time we're
going to add the round key which in this
case is XOR and then we're going to
repeat this process except for the last
round where we don't bother to mix the
columns because it doesn't really help
us I mean at the end we add in our final
round key and that's the end and out
comes the 128-bit block of total
gibberish this can be described as kind
of a random permutation that is to say
it takes some input and it performs what
appears to be complete landing ly
producing an output when a fat actually
obviously has had quite a lot to do with
this key if you have the key you can
then undo it each of these steps has an
exact opposite step that we can go back
up through to undo this whole process
does this ever go wrong
you mean how so well it just seems to be
so many stages and so many I am
Sebastian if there's a very good
question because I guess there's two
answers to that question one is
technically no because they have what we
would call them test vectors which are
this is all zeros when you put this in
with this key this is what you should
get so you can test your algorithm quite
a lot before you would put it into
production but in terms of sort of
security issues actually yes right so if
you get this implementation wrong you
can kind of undermine the security of
this whole cipher there have been things
like cache timing attacks and
side-channel attacks where bits of K
have been leaked because people have not
given due care to how this is
implemented well never neat things about
is is because it's a standard it's now
in C
you hardware so there are AAS
instructions to perform one round and to
perform a final round and things on an
Intel and AMD chip and on others and
they are impervious to these kind of
attacks and they're also ridiculously
fast so if you're using a s on on a
well-equipped CPU with the right
instructions we can be talking gigabits
per second of encryption which is you
know pretty good so that's why something
like BitLocker or some kind of on disk
encryption you won't notice it you click
a file it's already decrypted it and
shown it to you before you can sort of
realize what's happened and it's because
of the speed of this kind of stuff we'll
talk a little bit more about Galois
fields because I mean I like the name so
first first of all please look up Galois
every scale wa on Wikipedia because he's
fascinating did he die in a duel he died
in a duel right having published three
landmark papers on finite fields and
polynomials and things right so I mean
I'm not a mathematician so I don't know
the whole history but this is that this
is a guy